[Music]
the world famous Ritz hotel in central
London is the scene of the next chapter
in Camilla's story
from mistress to monarchy
it's 16 months since the death of Diana
and Camilla has been keeping a low
profile with the British public but not
for much longer
[Music]
inside one of the hotel's elegant
function rooms Camilla and Prince
Charles are celebrating the 50th
birthday of Camilla's sister Annabelle
here tonight they've chosen to make
their relationship official the start of
the journey to public acceptance
operation Ritz masterminded by Prince
Charles's press expert Mark Boland
outside a scrum of 200 journalists and
photographers have gathered
this has been worked out to the nth
degree and very carefully worked out on
the back of public reaction
Camilla's understandably anxious is this
the right moment so soon after Diana's
death
a nation United in grief
Diana's friends in Britain and around
the world will be watching every step of
the way
for this is the people's farewell
to the people's princess I think when
Diana died Camilla had to take another
step back they'd started the process
to make the relationship acceptable and
clearly it was going to be a few months
where nobody really wanted to see her
this evening everything would change as
Camilla emerged through the doors of the
Ritz and
it's interesting camera shoes and
and from The Waiting press here we go
[Applause]
there are so many camera flashes that
the British epilepsy Association later
urged broadcasters not to reuse the
footage
for Camilla and Charles could this
really be the beginning of a journey to
public acceptance
please
[Music]
I'm Kate Burley and from Sky News this
is the final episode of Queen Camilla
For the Love of Charles
foreign
was now on the road to win over the same
tabloid press that had almost destroyed
her meet the mistress said the Sun at
last read the headline of the front of
the mirror
Royal author Phil Craig
because she was clearly quite cute about
how she handled the press and the edits
of the sun this relationship with
Camilla they would speak on the phone
perhaps weekly and she would just keep
that contact she didn't ever bad mouth
Diana to him and his back and forth with
Camilla was completely kept out of the
press and it wasn't just the tabloids
there was the queen and the teenage
princes William and Harry still mourning
the loss of their mother and needing the
support of Charles
according to friend Kathy Letts the pr
plan would only work if the public could
see Camilla's Lighter Side
Camilla's charm is more disarming than a
U.N peacekeeping boss you know she's
just deliciously self-deprecating and I
was talking to him about how she was
surviving that myopic gaze of the media
because at the time she was Public Enemy
Number One and I saw it in action so
many times that I knew that once the
public got to see that side of her and
got to know her better and stopped
judging her as as you know that through
that misogynist lens of the other woman
that they they would warm to her and
Friends believe that was the heart of
the pr plan just let it be yourself
so she's just brought to the table how
she is Grant Harold was Prince Charles
and Camilla's Royal Butler so she hasn't
tried to change it she just does it her
way which I think is the secret that is
the secret just being yourself and being
natural that's the secret to making it a
success she just did the best she could
with the job that she was given
but for some of the journalists watching
on and Sky News Royal correspondent
Simon McCoy it was going to take a lot
more and there was someone else to
consider
the Queen's primary concern was well the
effect on the monarchy which at the time
if Charles had come up there and said
I'm I will end up with Camilla one way
or another I think the monarchy would
have been in serious trouble because the
public would just not have worn it
[Music]
by the start of the century Camilla had
still to meet the queen and that was
something which played heavily on
Charles's mind
before long however he orchestrated the
perfect opportunity for the two most
important women in his life to meet
Charles hosts a 60th birthday party for
King Constantine of Greece at his
country home Highgrove the Queen Anne
Camilla both invited
the encounter was in private and so no
one knows exactly what transpired but
Royal Insider and commentator Giles
brandreth said this in his book Charles
and Camilla portrait of a love affair
the encounter as I understand it was
pretty perfunctory a curtsy from Camilla
a smile from her majesty a moment of
small talk and that was that
as meetings go it was not memorable but
it was certainly significant it enabled
the Daily Telegraph to report to its
readers the queen has finally recognized
Mrs Parker Bowles
from the summer of the year 2000 Charles
and Camilla were swimming towards the
Open Sea
shortly after that she began to
accompany Prince Charles to Royal
engagements charity events an occasional
Walkabout
the Future King wanted the press and the
public to know Camilla was here to stay
and it now appeared the queen was
accepting of this
[Music]
in 2002 she invited Camilla to her
golden jubilee a national celebration
marking her 50th year on the throne a
classical concert in The Gardens of
Buckingham Palace and an important seal
of approval
Camilla's integration into Royal life
continued alongside Prince Charles now
publicly on his arm
in 2005 it was Charles's turn to add his
seal of approval on the 10th of February
the prince asked Camilla to marry him
how are you feeling man
if you get down on one knee to propose
engagement ring was a Priceless Windsor
Family heirloom that belonged to the
Queen Mother
and PR plan was moving exactly in the
right direction
[Music]
it's a little bit chilly but it's
certainly not raining and none of those
blizzards that they were warning us
about
for 35 years I've reported on some of
the biggest stories in the world for Sky
News
for a variety of different reasons there
are some days you remember better than
others the 9th of April 2005 one such
day marriages divorces scandals they've
had them all
probably because I'd grown up in a
household where there'd always been a
big interest in the Royal Family
and this was a day when the Royal
Institution officially speaking as I
come to know it was about to head in a
direction that it never had before
Prince Charles now age 56 was to marry
Camilla Parker Bowles then 57.
wedding Jitters not helped by a late
date change to avoid a clash with a
funeral of Pope John Paul II
standing among the twenty thousand
people who'd line the streets of Windsor
I remember people asking where was the
queen
it was decided that the couple would
marry in a civil ceremony followed by a
religious blessing
today after 34 years they're going to
make that Fairy Tale come true for both
Prince Charles
officially Buckingham Palace said her
majesty had decided to stay away as the
couple wanted to keep things low-key
more fuel for the critics who said the
relationship damaged the Royal brands
princess Harry and William were there
and I remember thinking that Harry at
least despite everything had reached
some sort of acceptance
she's a wonderful woman and she's made
our father very very happy which is the
most important thing William and I love
it a bit get on really well with her
unlike the Charles and Diana spectacular
nearly 25 years before for this Civil
Service Camilla was not dressed as a
typical Royal bride
for their second ceremony at the castle
a Christian blessing Camilla wore a
full-length porcelain blue silk dress
just as they planned it understated
the thing about the wedding was it was
it wasn't a sit-down meal it was
canopies which is obviously quite
different what you imagine but for such
so many people it kind of made sense
Grant Harold is a former Royal Butler
it was great fun I think it was to show
that there are modern couple you know to
show this is a modern way of doing
things but this was a more modern
approach to it which I thought worked
quite quite well they were very happy
very relaxed the whole event was very
carefully managed to avoid any
controversy and it ended with an after
party organized by the queen and Prince
Philip
it was a Triumph against all the odds
Royal Watcher Simon McCoy she gave a
speech where the wedding people may
remember it was on the day of the Grand
National and she her speech reflected
that uh here here was her son and
Camilla if they were running the Grand
National well the son her son had just
crossed the Finishing Line with his
partner as such was a winner and and she
backed it completely because she by then
realized that the future of the monarchy
yes it was with Charles but perhaps
without Camilla at his side he he would
have struggled
after all these years Camilla finally
had her man
they'd overcome huge personal challenges
and done the unimaginable won the
approval of the queen but the long
journey to public acceptance which
started with operation Ritz remember
still wasn't complete there remained
doubts from the public who felt they
hadn't seen the real Camilla
Sky News Royal commentator and governor
of Edinburgh Castle Alistair Bruce
there was a period of some difficulty
around this marriage because people were
still holding strong views of support to
the late Princess of Wales and some
people felt uncomfortable that someone
was coming in to adopt her space as it
were and the King sensitive to this and
taking advice through the queen decided
that it would be better that his wife be
not called the Princess of Wales which
of course by by law she was
but she took the second title which is
Duchess of Cornwall
[Music]
let's remember how far Camilla had come
the tape the hounding the hate but there
was still much to do before she could be
fully accepted
Shira wanted to forge her own path
she turned to charity work wanting to
use her new platform particularly on the
topic of domestic violence
how many more within must be harrised
raped or murdered before we truly unite
to forge a violence-free world
she even agreed to a cameo role on the
BBC's EastEnders to convey her message
this is for all victims of domestic
abuse yes it is it's very important that
she's remembered it's so important and
there have been secret trips to support
centers and shelters too
here's CEO of Refuge Ruth Davidson
having a bvip visitor to come to a
refuge is very intimidating when she
came and visited a refuge recently she
just came in sat at the kitchen table
with a woman who was making breakfast
for her children with another woman who
was in her pajamas having her breakfast
and she just fitted alongside them just
Woman to Woman person to person and I
think that probably isn't what they were
expecting from a member of the royal
family but this very human very Personal
Touch was immediately evident she didn't
need special treatment she didn't need
special drinks she didn't bring her own
things with her she was happy just to
sit alongside people's peers and listen
to their story and talk with them
finally the public was seeing a
different Camilla
she was now in control of Her Own Story
one that had been for so long written by
her critics in the Press
good friend Kathy Lett knew it would
happen eventually
I organized helped organize a Bushfire
memorial service and we're all Cathedral
it was very moving and we raised a lot
of money too for the victims Etc and I
was in the meet and greet queue because
I've been one of the organizers and I
could see Camilla and Charles walking
towards me and Camilla smiled and kissed
me on the cheek and I said Hi how are
you where have you been what have you
been doing she said oh actually just got
back from Brazil and I was like oh my
God that's a long way to go for a wax
and Camilla just threw her head back and
cackled like a kookaburra
thank you
the royal couple continued to enjoy many
happy years together Camilla looked like
an established part of the family by the
time of the 2022 Platinum Jubilee
[Applause]
of course the inevitable day would come
and Charles must step up to the role
he'd been preparing for all of his life
we have some very important news
Buckingham Palace has just announced
that her majesty Queen Elizabeth II has
died
she was 96 years old Queen on the
afternoon of the 8th of September 2022 I
along with millions of others all around
the world learned of the death of Queen
Elizabeth II
come to the throne more than 70 years
earlier at the age of just 25 following
the early death of her own father King
George VI
she was the country's longest reigning
monarch
it was a moment of huge National
significance grief and disbelief for a
commonwealth that had only known Queen
Elizabeth on the throne the nation's
grandmother
had passed
it's a day we've been preparing for
since the launch of Sky News in the
1980s but the inevitable
was no less distressing the sovereigners
home the minute gun fires the Sebastopol
bell rings
and a view of the people she served
stretching away
on the long walk
[Music]
this was a seminal moment for the
Commonwealth the end of one era the
beginning of another the longest serving
Heir Apparent a man who he'd only ever
known as either the Prince of Wales or
Prince Charles
some thought he may choose to be King
George Arthur or Philip his middle names
he eventually chose to rule by his own
name King Charles III
this is also a time of change for my
family
I count on the loving help of my darling
wife Camilla
in recognition of her own loyal Public
Service since I married 17 years ago
she becomes my queen consort
and not only did we have a new king but
we had a new Queen in waiting a queen
consort in those early days of the death
of Queen Elizabeth much was to change
Camilla age 75 now stood quietly beside
her husband as he made his first speech
as king
grieving for the loss of his beloved
mother and with a weight of Duty on his
septuagenarian shoulders
for most of my career her relationship
with Charles played out in private and
only occasionally but devastatingly
bursting into the public Arena I need
you all
all the time the tapes the TV interviews
this is Taco Bells is
a great friend of mine here we go
sink back again
no longer the queen consort was the
King's Rock
Simon McCoy
I remember when it was clear that
Charles and Camilla were going to get
married the the spin put on it was that
she doesn't want to be Queen she's not
interested in becoming Queen which was
very clever because it removed a big
issue from the conversation about what
her role should be then later on it was
let known that she would be happy to be
princess consort and everybody said oh
hello that's okay that's probably
dealable with and each time they gauge
the public reaction and each time the
public sort of warmed to it got used to
it and this latest step is the
inevitable next step to that and the
next step after Queen Camilla will be
it'll just be the king and the Queen
not so long ago there were worries about
Camilla assuming Diana's title now she
would take on the highest title for a
consort
remember just how far she'd come the
most hated woman in Britain
but Camilla and Charles survived the
intrusions and the headlines and fought
their way through
what a journey she'd undertaken to
arrive here which had eventually Against
All Odds resulted in an acceptance by
the press and the public
[Applause]
again their relevance is through the
work that they do with young people and
that they keep themselves current they
have an engagement portfolio that takes
them into every single Walk of Life
she has been store worked in her support
of him her Devotion to him and also in
saying enough is enough when she feels
he's working too hard I really like to
think of her as a Steel Magnolia
the drama though wasn't quite over
Prince Harry's Memoir spare published in
January of 2023 rubbed salt in the
wounds particularly in this interview
with American networks CBS
she was the villain
she was the third person in the marriage
she needed to rehabilitate her image
nevertheless just a month before the
coronation the royal family confirmed
Camilla will be known as Queen
the couple recently celebrated their
18th wedding anniversary and appear as
happy today as they did on their wedding
day in 2005.
a final thought from our Royal expert
Alistair Bruce
what I have loved seeing
from Camilla as Duchess or as previous
girlfriend and supporter in the early
stages and right through to now as Queen
is that no matter your view of the
situation there is no doubt that this
woman really has
given the king a great deal of
self-confidence and support and it's a
job like no other it's an existence more
than a job and it's not a place to be
lonely or without support So this rain
will depend for its success
in no small part
on Camilla
through these challenges from her first
explosive and deeply embarrassing
introduction into the public
Consciousness to her coronation as Queen
for Camilla it's all been for love
For the Love of Charles
[Music]
Queen Camilla For the Love of Charles is
a Sky News podcast production presented
by me K Burley you can listen to all
three episodes now
the producer is soiler apparisio
assistant producers are Alex Eden and
Lily Thomas sound design is by James
Bradshaw Rob mulhern is the exec
producer and Paul stanworth the editor